so what you do is you put it out there
so you can see it
so you you've got to shine the hands
like i said if you do this thinking oh
you'll come round and get it
i should see my media
oh you're gonna do much easier one than
that you're gonna catch him up so you're
gonna offer this and then
[Music]
here
i was trying to give everybody something
everything's complete i remember the
first time i ever tried
aikido
tai chi i felt like an elephant doing
tai chi
but you know
that's how it goes you know
but the next day i remember my first day
i could i still remember i still
remember when i was walking at 11
o'clock the next day and i thought
do you know i don't know what i'd done
last night i really enjoyed it
um
i did enjoy was we were training in a
due um
that was a little tiny top school where
the tag was a bit this high all i can
remember is every time i got out of the
lord
i somehow seem to be thrown
always under a perfect table i was
confused
didn't know what i was doing like
as i said
like that and then
trying to you know be on balance so
don't worry if it's difficult
everything's difficult
the people who have been doing a little
while will help you
not that will help